president Trump you were part of a roast
a Donald Trump roast in 2011 yes
do you recall your joke about him
running for president in 2011 remember
what the joke was it was something about
him running some black people out of the
White House
why weren't some black people out of a
hospital he was used to that anyway some
he was doing his whole life Joe close to
that yeah yeah I think it was yeah
I think it was like you'll be it's not
the first time you've forced a black
family out of a home I like that I'm
reminding you and then you hear it and
you laugh like you're hearing it do you
think he's doing a good job a great job
or a terrible job who me
no not you the no I mean the people here
no not Adam and them in charge no no I'm
just saying whose opinion or you ask you
asking the crowd are you asking I'm
asking you
oh you're asking me how do I think Trump
is doing doing a good job a great job I
love that it's good great or then you
suddenly it's terrible I think I think
he's having a lot of difficulties I
think the job is not what he thought it
would be I don't think he necessarily
intended to get this job what do you
think I'm hitting I think it you right I
think it's more than times when you go
in and you fill out an application are
you really not trying to get the job and
like I'm just gonna fill inside and all
of a sudden they call you black you know
you got to what
like it's like he filled out an
application for Burger King I really
don't want to work there nothing against
Burger King you guys are killing it
right do they buy time on the show Jeff
Burger King they do okay they got new
chili dog the new chili dog chili dog
they're killing it with the chili dog at
Burger King you had Burger King dear
Burger King who doesn't buy time on the
show what fast food chain is there one
that just doesn't buy in at all who
called you Junior wait dad no way yeah
let me [ __ ] drive past Paul jr. they go
to Jack in the Box oh can you drive
right past Carl's jr. to go to Jack
that's right
you
you